hello everyone how's everyone today
hopefully better than me and yeah today
we're gonna kinda wrap it up for
mathematical physics we were discussing
this week whether mathematical physics
is rational and the answer is no it's
not
we have some very objective criteria for
what is rational and mathematical
physicists do not meet that criterion
and they don't have to I mean they might
come up with something else and that's
fine we'll find out well we'll discuss
if they can come up with what they
consider rational or irrational right
but unless they come with their version
of what rationality is what we're
proposing sticks you know they they're
debate or they run away that that's it
there and then got no other option and
right now
you know they're running away so far we
have no takers
no one who wants to discuss rationality
and likewise they don't want to discuss
you know what an explanation is versus
what a description is they describe
mathematics only describes they hint
insinuate that they also explain which
they don't and so we have to define what
we mean by explanation what we mean by
description and last two or three videos
you got to watch them to get an idea of
what we're proposing okay so let's just
go over what we went over yesterday real
quick we've got a definition for a
mathematical physicist of mathematical
physics is an individual who explains
phenomena using concepts as objects and
second it's an individual who can't tell
the difference between an adjective and
an adverb and let me tell you why just
real quick use adjectives to qualify
objects structure and mathematical
physics physicists mathematical physics
in general doesn't deal with objects
doesn't care about objects and that's
the big problem they don't care about
objects and it turns out you can't do
physics without objects you can't do
physics without things and so that's
where the problem starts and what these
people do is they look at behavior not
at objects they look at how an object
behaves and they're not concerned about
the structure the architecture or you
know what something looks like and that
creates problems because you know they
don't care if they talk about a point
particle massless volume less no volume
no mass nothing and they move that
nothing around
that's the problem that's not physics
that's nonsense that's what it is what
they claim is that you know they're only
gonna be concerned about the behavior of
something they can put an equation that
describes that motion but they're not
concerned about what it looks like what
what it is and that's important and it's
important because physics only deals
with objects so you have to identify the
objects to begin with otherwise you're
not doing physics period and that's
where we have disagreement so what are
some of the rationality is a
mathematical physicist proposed I just
had an impromptu list here
he's unconcerned with structure draws a
dot on the board calls it a point tells
you that it's zero dimensional and
constructs one-dimensional lines with
positions and ordered pairs concepts he
tells you that the universe is infinite
but because he can run around a surface
or bounding continuously when he
actually means incessantly so it doesn't
have to do with continuous and it
doesn't have to do with infinity whether
an object is infinite it's got to do
with motion around an object they say
that's incessant and they call that
infinity because what they do with
equations is you know describe motion
and they say oh if an object moves
incessantly we'll call that infinity
that's infinite for a mathematician he
tells you that a line is straight when
he actually means that the itinerary is
rectilinear in other words he's not
talking about a line a steak he's not
talking about a curtain rod he's talking
about motion he's saying let's the
trajectory the motion the path is
rectilinear and he calls that a straight
line he represents it with a straight
line and so he confuses you because
you're looking at the straight line he
says no don't take it literally I'm not
referring to that curtain rod that
you're looking at that straight rod no
no I'm talking about something else I'm
talking about the motion
particle or whatever and that's he calls
that straight it's not straight it's
rectilinear it's a motion number five
says that light turns around the Sun
when he actually means that the tiny
discrete photon swerves as a result of
or is deflected by the trivia Chur of
space-time in other words if space-time
is curved fine then let's concede that
for this for the sake of the
conversation or discussion then he can't
say that this is discrete photon is
curved you know that light is curved he
can say that the photon is being
deflected by the curvature of space-time
that's the correct way to phrase that
and not to say that light is curved
which is what they say okay so this is
more than just semantics it's got to do
with what the guy is introducing and
here's another list another quick one
here and he tells you that a star
compress is gravitational to such
extremes that it becomes a region of
something else here you have a
standalone star it's compressing it's
shrinking right all the mass is being
concentrated at a point and that thing
becomes a region of space-time of
something else
you try to figure it out he says that a
particle he mentions the word particle
when he means field and what is the
field the field is a region made up of
values and potentials and quantities in
other words a field is not a physical
object it's a concept and he calls that
a particle and that's where he misleads
you
he claims that at the center of every
galaxy there is a singularity and this
volume loves infinite mass he emits Jets
so there's nothing there there's no no
volume it's infinite mass whatever that
means because they've never defined mass
and this non non entity emits Jets he
asserts that every galaxy is
encapsulated in an invisible ultra heavy
known as dark matter that compels the
stars on the outside of the galaxy to
travel as fast or faster than those on
the inside it's near the center ok and
why did they do that because that's what
they observe they had to describe it
somehow and they so that said ok let's
sprinkle some kilograms on the outside
of a galaxy to mimic what a galaxy is
doing well what they observe when they
look at galaxies out there is that a
galaxy the Stars on the outside they
looked at many galaxies especially
spiral galaxies they say you know for
some reason the stars on the outside are
moving faster than those on the inside
it just imagined just just for the sake
of argument so that you can picture what
they're referring to Pluto
takes what 248 years to go around the
Sun and Earth years right 248 years
earth years to go no no no let me think
let me finish so that you see the
comparison mercury which is closer to
this much closer to the Sun takes only
88 days earth days to go around the Sun
right so so this guy's got the inside
track he goes out mercury goes real fast
88 days he's around the Sun and Pluto
which is so far away takes 243 or 248
years to go around the Sun and we all
understand that you know if you take a
ball at the end of a string and you
swirl it around your head you know the
ball goes a certain speed as long as
that string is let's say 2 feet long now
make it a mile long well it's gonna take
a long time to go around your head
period right that's not what happens
with a galaxy with a galaxy the guy on
the outside is going faster than the guy
on the inside but you say faster boy you
really mean
it's going this the that same speed but
it's it's it's kind of like they're all
lined up yeah but running the other one
it is because if it's they're all lined
up they move around like carousel like a
carousel right and that means that the
buggies on the outside or the horsies on
the outside go as fast as the buggies on
the inside and we can all understand
that with a carousel we have no problem
with a carousel because we say well
there are not same platform right but
what's the platform out there in in
space and they say well let's fix this
we sprinkle kilograms on the outside of
a galaxy and we fix the problem
now our equations work right because now
the way they fix it is they created this
variable called dark matter which is
just a variable in an equation that's
all it is and what they do is they say
well if we make this it heavy enough we
can we can mimic we can simulate what's
happening with the galaxies they can fix
the problem by kind of invoking like
there must be kilograms somewhere around
here and with the if if there were
kilograms here here and here then this
phenomenon would make sense but this is
one explanation again we're back to
failure of the imagination yeah oh it is
is let's fix the problem how do they fix
the problem they say let's create a
variable and let's put a lot of
kilograms in there mass that's all they
do they put more mass in out there and
they say oh now we fixed the problem now
we can simulate what's happening out
there we can do it in our computers if
we sprinkle more mass out there whatever
mass is then then we can now make the
galaxies rotate like what we observe
that's how they fix the problem by that
same token I can draw an angel behind
every
and I can also solve the problem exactly
let's assume it's loaded on the outside
have more angels let's let's assume we
get rid of mass let's put angels God
sends his angels on the outside of a
galaxy no problem and he and he
instructs them look you know on the
outside I want you to move those stars
faster and faster and faster so they
keep up with those on the inside or even
pass them and that's what these people
are doing they're creating angels and
you call these angels kilograms that's
what it is and they refer to this as
dark matter dark angels I don't know
call it whatever you want it's just uh
it's an ad-hoc solution they simply have
to fix the problem and they only fix it
mathematically they have not figured out
you know from a physical standpoint what
could be doing that and they just say
well it's dark matter and what is dark
matter what's invisible ultra heavy
stuff why is it only on the outside
oh we don't know God just sprinkled it
there because he had a headache one day
that's it I mean why is it why isn't
happening I mean why is it dark matter
between the earth and the Sun and the
Sun or the earth and the moon why didn't
God sprinkle it there because of course
if God sprinkles dark matter between the
earth and the moon neither Einstein or
Newton work neither of those equations
work
why didn't you I put dark matter between
the earth and the moon that's an
unscientific question we're done any
question you don't like unsanitary but I
see you defend um angels you crap on the
mathematical physicist well I don't have
angels a lot of time to think there's
actually a Christian yeah this I'll go
with angels celibate of God anyway
another televangelist here people I'll
go with God over space-time any day I
can imagine God right see he's a
magician with a magic wand he's got a
beard white hair billion years
in existence whatever we can all imagine
god no one can imagine space-time
four-dimensional space-time so yeah I'll
take God over space-time any day
Christianity beats mathematical physics
with its eyes closed by autumns razor so
okay so these are the problems with
mathematical physics now what's today
about well I want to attack I'm gonna be
criticizing one of the prolific writers
in kora
his name is Victor Toth he's a he's not
a physicist he's a math magician he does
everything with magic okay and he uses
mathematics he doesn't care about the
consequences he doesn't care about you
know what are the physical
interpretations he disregards oh he
doesn't care if it they're irrational
he's just gonna concentrate on equations
he's a mathematician all he does his
equations and I got you talking about it
there murdering people he doesn't care
about the consequence yeah yeah yeah
yeah collateral damage that these people
are causing but they're mad but that's
what it is because people have respect
for mathematicians they say oh this
guy's you know he's very versatile with
you know he's very skilled with math so
he's got to be a genius no these people
are autistic people they should be
locked up that's what it is they should
be locked up because all they do all day
is do mathematics they do equations
that's what they love to do and and and
yeah and they lose track of reality they
have no idea what reality looks like
they give a physical interpretation
which is irrational and they say well
yeah take it or leave it that's what we
can pull it in
yeah they don't care and I'm the
smartest guy you got this is what I got
so take it or leave it
what are you what are you gonna do like
this do what are you gonna do yeah yeah
and so the question is whether you go
with someone like that who gives you
some irrational explanation or you come
back with your feet on the ground and
you look at reality okay most people
just buy it by getting their feet on the
ground they just go to do something else
because obviously this physic stuff is
worse than magic it is worse than man
it's good for a Hollywood Hollywood
loves it because they can create all
these movies you know with back to the
future and you know particles being
places there's no one is the worst or or
what that what is it Star Trek the guy
is beamed down to a planet what did he
call the when they transfer someone I
know it's called teleporting yeah
telephone that's the word I was under so
they teleport you they love all this
stuff and they say oh we're not doing
fiction we're not doing man this is
physics that's the problem because these
are technology we haven't gotten yet
yeah and and these are the physical
interpretations that are inferred or
derived from mathematicians and let me
let me give a specific here so that you
can have some fun with it
here we have Victor Toth and he deals
the subject of momentum momentum is that
little P there in the equation momentum
okay it's the P not the M okay man
the M is mass mass okay and the V is
velocity and so momentum is mass times
velocity P equals mV straightforward no
problem there but he says but this is
not true for particles moving at or near
the speed of light including the photon
right there is another relationship
involving momentum so instead of using
the traditional classical p equals MV he
use
the P equals e / C EB and energy and
little C being the velocity of light so
he says that when you deal with things
such as the photon or anything that
travels near the speed of light maybe
the muon or Payan or any of those
particles that they when or the neutrino
when they need them to go at the
velocity of light they just you know
hand waving and they say it goes at the
speed of light fine okay so what is the
momentum of such a particle
well you don't use the P equals mV you
use the P equals E over C what does this
mean what is this a sleight of hand what
does it entail
well it tails that says this is the
momentum of the photon which has no mass
but it has energy see there's no mass in
in the equation P equals E over C and
you say oh how can that be if energy is
equal to mass you've heard of Einstein's
equation e equals mc-squared
energy is equal mass times the velocity
of the light square in other words mass
is a different form of energy energy is
a different form of mass they're
interchangeable yeah and these people
are saying look don't use the P equals
mV
P equals you know man momentum equals
mass times velocity now we don't like
that for the photon let's use P equals
energy over the velocity of light over
the velocity of light real quick to that
yeah interesting that that says a lot
about math the limits of it because with
math with an equation or a formula
you're just trying to balance out the
equation yeah or or get a number so all
the variables are kind of on the same
level you can they're all
interchangeable you can throw them all
around like like mass can be light can
be momentum can be speed can be weigh
zero me or infinite it's like it's
important to know that yeah but my point
is the variables themselves like the
properties like location can be speed
for all they care about
that's velocity
they can change the note as long as
they're numbers they almost don't care
what they're throwing around remember
velocity is a very strange type of a
thing because concept right because
velocity is only valid for a given point
you would say the velocity a point I
thought that was location but see
they're saying the particle has a
certain velocity at this exact point and
time think about that for a second yeah
in other words what they're saying
remember velocity is only for one point
for one location they say the particle
or whatever the stone has a certain
velocity at this point at this time and
another points got a different velocity
a different you know different velocity
not speed but velocity so velocity is
only valid for a given point a given
time employ a space time right okay
keep that in mind okay velocity is not
valid for forever just only valid for a
given point okay but the point here that
is the Toth is saying look you know P
equals MV we don't use that for light we
don't use that for maybe neutrinos pi
ons and muons whatever all those
particles that travel near the speed of
light maybe tachyons Hooten which travel
even faster i don't know what what the
momentum of a tachyon would be but the
point here is that you don't use that
formula that's the classical formula
that's good for stones yeah crowbars
trees anything you throw at someone
that's okay but if you're gonna use
something that travels near the speed of
light you have to use the bottom
equation P equals energy over the
velocity of light squared fine what is
the problem the first one is that you
know they they choose and they say well
we're not gonna use the first one
that's the first problem okay because
they're kind of very particular which
equation they're gonna use to get their
theory across right okay the second one
is that you know energy is equal to mass
and mass is equal to energy there are
different forms
you know energies at different form of
mass masses atom form of energy so by
check by saying equals over see they
have not gotten rid of mass but they're
saying well you know we got rid of mass
the rest mass now when we deal with
energy were using dynamic mass what is
it which is known in mathematical
physics as relativistic mass think of it
as this this way an elephant right you
put him on the scale he weighs a lot
right but he weighs a little more if you
throw him on the scale from above so
it's not the same for the elephant just
to stand on the scale then to throw
against the scale obviously the elephant
would weigh more or the scale would show
a greater value
if you throw the elephant against the
scale and this is what they're talking
about they're saying look when the
elephant stands on the scale he weighs
zero but when you throw the elephant
against the scale he weighs more than
zero so the rest mass of the photon
standing on the scale is zero but when
you throw the photon against the scale
now it has relativistic mass which is
greater than zero that's what these
people are saying understood I hope
that's clear okay you throw the photon
against the scale it weighs something if
it just stands there and it weighs
nothing okay that's what they're saying
that's the difference between rest mass
and relativistic or dynamic mass you
throw them it's got velocity it's coming
with with momentum okay
and the momentum not the top one it's
the bottom one the energy one not the
mass one okay but what is the the
underlying problem with all of this
well the underlying problem with all of
this is that we have no idea what
they're talking about and your symbol
what do you mean you don't have any idea
what they're talking about
no see to this day how many years has it
been two thousand three thousand okay
let's let's let's be on the air side a
little bit let's just talk at least
since Newton 17th century were talking
about four hundred years at least four
hundred years no one no one on earth has
defined a word mass and a word energy we
have no idea what the word mass means or
what the word energy means so they could
have put a little m they could have been
put Big E forget about those those
variables those those letters let's use
a cue how's that you like the letter Q
ok let's use Q P equals Q times a they
can't tell you what Q is
and they say P is equal to what's
another good letter s you like s s over
C they have no idea what s is or they
can't define this letter S so what have
we learned we don't know what Q is we
don't know what s is
and they say P is equal to s over little
C so they'll see we know it's 300,000
kilometers per second that's the
velocity of light no problem there P
we're trying to find out that's momentum
but we don't know what s is that's
supposedly the energy what is energy we
don't know and here don't take it from
me you know I'm a nobody
you don't take you know stuff that from
nobodies like me no let's let's uh let's
go here here you have Edwin Taylor John
Wheeler anyone who's done a little bit
of physics at least recognizes
wheeler he died short while ago and he
was a very important guy in mathematical
physics and he says the following nature
does not offer us any concept as the
amount of matter we always learn in high
school that mass is the amount of matter
of the elephant well these people are
saying no that's not true
history has struck down every proposal
to define such a term we have no
definition of mass even if we could
count number of atoms or by any other
counting method try to evaluate amount
of matter that number would not equal
mass to this day we have no idea what
mass is what what the word mass means in
fact if you look up the word mass like
on a Wikipedia it'll tell you that
there's several definitions of mass you
got related relativistic mass which I
covered a second ago that's throwing the
elephant against the scale
you got rest mass I mean if it's the
quantity of matter it's very simple
let's assume that the unit of matter is
the hydrogen atom just just for the sake
of argument right all we have to do is
count the number of hydrogen atoms
there's ten of them we have ten masses
period ten units of mass it's very
simple you count and these people are
saying you can't do that because that's
not how they do how they do it in
mathematical physics remember the way
they do this is not by counting atoms
they look at the scale they say if you
throw the elephant on the scale how many
kilograms does he weigh and they come up
with I don't know a thousand kilograms
fine so how many how much how many units
of mass is a hundred thousand kilograms
but they don't know they can't relate
one to the other and they say look here
we're going to deal with dynamic mass
with relativistic mass and here we're
going to use a quantity of matter
10 10 units of mass 10 hydrogen atoms
whatever that's the problem why is it so
hard to pinpoint weight or mass you know
what the unit is essentially what what
is it that you would have to count or
what is the basic unit of weight I guess
well its suppressing by the way let me
just finish there it's an early yeah
yeah I'll address it right now it is
important to realize in physics today we
have no knowledge of what energy is so
we don't know what energy is or what
mass is ok I just wanted to finish that
but let's address the question here the
question is what was the unit of mass
what we were using unit yeah what is the
smallest what is the thing that weighs
the least I guess would be the question
that's not the question no the question
is something else let's clarify the
question before we answer the question
he's asking after right the unit of mass
is the kilogram kept in Paris France
there's a standard there since the 19th
century and it was deemed by God to be
right the unit of mass it's the kilogram
kept in Paris France and it can only be
kept at a certain temperature and at a
certain latitude and longitude because
if as soon as you move that to the North
Pole or to the equator the mass changes
keep that in mind
it changes Y B can you say the mass
changed
yeah the mass changed no that it can't
be because the amount of matter did not
change yeah but see the way they
determine is that by counting atoms they
do it by weighing it see what
mathematician will has never discovered
is that counting is different than
measuring and measuring is different
than counting counting is very simple
you just count units 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so
it's got to be integers yeah you have a
thousand apples you can't have a
thousand point five apples right you
have a
thousand apples and now the question is
how much they weigh
okay so let's weigh him and you weigh
them and you come up with so many
kilograms
well can you say that you know 10
kilograms is equal to a thousand apples
can you do that no you can't you can't
for everything that you find out there
can we do that with iron we take bowling
balls okay we have 100 bowling balls
away and we count them 100 bowling balls
do they weigh so much in comparison to
apples no they don't they have a
different weight altogether and so you
get thrown off by what you said earlier
yeah
weight in Paris where it depends on
where where it's at where it's at if
you're on a mountain it's gonna weigh
less than if you're at the bottom of the
sea and in fact that's the case when you
take the standard a kilogram from Paris
and you take to the North Pole well the
the earth is oblate its flattened out at
the poles and enlarged at the equator so
but if you're at the North Pole you're
closer to the center of the earth and
you are if you are at the equator just a
little bit but it doesn't matter the
point is the earth is oblate that means
it's flattened out from pole to pole and
wide at the equator this creates two
problems the first one is your closer to
the center of the earth if you're at the
North or South Pole then you are at the
equator that's the first one the second
one is the Earth rotates at the equator
around the equator very close to it it's
really a little slanted 24 degrees but
let's let's assume it's rotating around
the equator so you're being thrown
outwards at the equator you're not being
thrown outwards when you stand you know
at like if you're on a carousel if
you're at the edge of the carousel you
you feel the you know you gotta hang on
otherwise though tarah so will throw you
out but if you're in the center of the
carousel you say what's what's the
problem with him you know I don't see
anything I don't feel anything right
because you're rotating around your
center point and that's
issue also with yeah with wait so if you
take the kilogram from Paris to the
North Pole
not only you don't feel the the
centrifugal force of the equator but
you're also closer to the center of the
earth so both act to make the kilogram
right less heavy
let's kilogram me yeah yes yeah it's
also like if you go into water yeah yeah
also yeah but medium yeah so if you're
in the air versus water versus like
steel or a vacuum yeah yeah you're gonna
weigh less as well or different you know
in each of these different media so what
is the issue the issue is that they have
never never in the history of life on
earth been able to separate mass from
kill from weight weight and mass are the
same things and they say no no no you're
an idiot what are you saying
yeah mass and weight are the same thing
and they say no it's different okay so
what how are they different they say
mass is different because mass is the
quantity of matter and right now we're
showing that it's not because the way
they determine the mass of an object is
by weighing it they do it the same way
as we're weight and you say well but if
you take it to the moon that way it's
differently yet weighs differently and
the mass is different you say no the
mass has not changed because the number
of atoms are the same well we don't
count atoms we weigh it because we're
only interested in the effect of it
right what is what would affect or what
displacement how does it affect the
outside world like the scale
exactly because we're only carrying
caring about effects not objects right
back to that we're always we're always
about effects they don't care but then
looks like how many atoms it's got
things they don't look at water bottle
its effect is one kilogram but the
problem with that it becomes again like
we said its effect here is one kilogram
but
on Mount Everest it's not one killer and
that's why wait they don't like to deal
with weight because weights very
wishy-washy like when they go to mass
that we got the same problem because
they determine mass by weighing that's
interesting counting you're right it was
integers you can't go wrong it three is
always three is always three we just
have to do trip boat with weight three
here and three there are now different
when we're talking about the weight of
the three but see if if if we did not
measure if instead we counted it would
be straight forward then we could be
rational we could say okay we're gonna
these we're not gonna use that standard
in France we don't care about that let's
simply make the standard the hydrogen
atom how many hydrogen atoms does this
object have and if it's made out of
uranium which is ninety two hydrogen
atoms we just count them as 92 if it's
carbon it's what twelve okay so we'll
just use twelve or whatever oxygenate
we'll use a so so we just convert the
element into hydrogen atoms and we count
hydrogen atoms then it's straightforward
we say how many hydrogen atoms does this
have and we count them we don't we don't
weigh them we count them so it doesn't
matter if you're on the moon if you're
under the North Pole we just count atoms
and we'll know what mass is but as long
as we we measure and we weigh and put it
on a scale we'll never know the
difference between mass and weight but
what I'm saying here is yeah of course
it's not practice aying here is that
it's objected that is definitely one way
to set price and weight right it's the
only way counting counting versus the
way that we can think of yeah counting
versus measuring then you're okay and so
you know here again we don't know what
mass is we don't know what energy is
because these words that have never
defined and this with these people like
Victor Toth based their entire theory on
or their entire argument on so I'm the
so all we have to say is look when you
when you finally have a definition for
mass when you finally have a definition
for energy will allow you to come back
to the conference room meanwhile stay in
your basement do your little squiggly
equations we don't care about those when
you come to conference have a definition
we want to know what you mean by the
word mass we want to know what you mean
by the word energy and you know it
doesn't stop there here we have mr. Toth
and he also deals with the word time and
he's a part-time physicist I'm is so I
guess that that would go in in that
direction as well you have to define
what what a part-timer is if you don't
know what time is right anyways he says
modern physics can be mysterious whoa
but not that mysterious okay thank God
you know it always astonishes me how
people including some professional
physicists at times managed to confuse
themselves so badly oh thank god he's
gonna clarify a lot of stuff here they
start questioning the existence of even
the most obvious things around them this
time exist check your watch
the space exists check your meter stick
is gravity a force you tell me after you
drop a brick on your foot is motion and
illusion ask again after you run
headfirst into a brick wall does matter
exist again I would recommend various
convincing tricks with the
aforementioned bricks
so mr. Toth apparently proves everything
through experiments that's what I've
seen I get out of this he says run an
experiment you'll find out if time
exists you know running experiment to
see if space exists so we run an
experiment to see if there's a force if
there's uh you know whatever motion
or whatever and that's what he has been
trained to do this is what he was
educated to doing this is how he abused
the world he says physics modern physics
in particular maybe abstract and
difficult to learn no it's irrational
now not difficult again they use these
words like difficult and
counterintuitive no it's irrational
because they're using concepts as
objects that's why it's irrational wait
how would you what do you say establish
the time exists or the question the way
we do it in science the way we do it in
physics and real physics is we define
the word exist then we know what we're
talking about unless you define the word
exists you don't know if God exists or
not exist
you can discuss all day long a theist
against an atheist you know they'll go
around in circles together with the
agnostic know all three of them go in
circles why because they never defined
the word exist an easy way to see if
you're using the word right is to
replace it with the word X mm-hmm yeah
because whenever you don't care about
the Luverne we care about the definition
we care about the notion what is it
actually trying to express yeah and
unless you define the word exist you
don't know what you're talking about
don't you knowing you you're expressing
right no one can tell you if you say
exist person a understands a person B
understands B you understand C so we're
all just talking past each other C and
the problem like in the case of God
people have for centuries
atheists against thei especially and
agnostics they've always worried about
the wrong word they're worried about the
word god and there is an issue there but
that's not the important word the word
the important word is the word exist
what do we mean by the word exist and
all you have to go do is go to the
stanford encyclopedia of philosophy or
go to the catholic encyclopedia look at
the word exist or existence or anything
similar to those
and you'll find that to this day no one
has defined a word so when people say
God exists have crappy no no yeah you
know run around no no they have nothing
their definition right synonymous
definitions that's what it is giving
crappy definitions that they don't
really give you any more information
about the word right give you words that
or the best way that we cut through all
that is with conditions or with criteria
what are what are the criteria to call
something exists right and and this is
the issue the issue is that they have
not defined a crucial word and the
crucial word is not God the crew I mean
it is you have to define both of them
well let me let me just say let me just
say under word God very quickly you have
to determine whether God is an object
anthropomorphic being or a concept love
intelligence grace whatever you have to
separate that that's that's the only
issue about God but that's not the
important word the important word is the
word exist what do you mean when you say
God exists what do you mean whether you
say God does not exist and unless you
define the word exists you're gonna go
around in circles forever yeah I mean
God can make the issue complicated let's
make it easier say yeah sure you have a
chair right okay what do you mean by
exist right and and we're done and it
sounds like like like like simple simple
how basic do you need a make this but
then you try to define the word or give
criteria for the word criteria for the
word that they exclude everything that
does not exist and includes everything
that does exist as per your use of the
word exist you have to find the criteria
that excludes everything you don't want
like I don't know ghosts and and
whatever whatever you'll leave pixels on
the screen whatever you believe does not
exist has to be excluded from from your
definition and whatever you believe does
exist has to be included in your
definition just so we can understand you
and use the word right and that's the
issue the issue is the word exist and so
when thought says that time exists
we have no idea what he's talking about
not because he's using the word time but
because he's using the word exist we
have no idea what he's talking about
first of all he he can I'm sure 100%
sure he cannot define the word time
because no one has in the last 2,000
years yeah I mean very loosely have the
circular definitions or synonyms
I'll bet Victor pathi million bucks he
cannot define the word time he hasn't
defined it yell either give a synonym or
he'll he'll say how to measure it or
what it is not or he'll go through a lot
of stuff like that but he will not
define it scientifically and and again
that's not the important word the
important word in his phrase is whether
it exists or not and again you know he
says modern physics is particular maybe
abstract and difficult to learn no it's
irrational and we're not talking about
physical we're talking about
mathematical physics the irrationality
that comes out of Cambridge and Harvard
that's what we're talking about the
physics departments in those monasteries
it's all irrational and that's why he
says it's difficult it's
counterintuitive it's it's you know it's
unintuitive no it's irrational and he
says again contradicting everyday
intuition you know of course we're
seeing it's irrational he can praise it
in a million ways what he's talking
about is irrationality and they say well
it's counterintuitive it's difficult
no even they don't understand it in fact
they they say you know they stated that
nobody understands quantum mechanics so
it's not only you it's they themselves
that don't understand it after taking
ten years at the University okay so but
physics is not about questioning reality
it is about explaining how reality does
what we observe okay so please explain
how it does what we observe
we observe a magnet attracting another
here we have a magnet attracting another
I would like to show this I love this
one and then when you turn them upside
down they hate each other and so that's
what we observe and he says physics is
about explaining what we observe okay I
observe two pieces of metal attracting
each other what's the explanation what's
the mechanism and again you know Viktor
Toth will never give you an answer to
that he will describe it he will say
look the force is so much there's so
many Gauss involved if you put a charged
particle in the in the middle it'll move
at such speed he'll give you a lot of
nonsense mathematical nonsense that has
nothing to do with physics he will not
explain the mechanism and I always give
that analogy you go to the show a
mathematician tells you not how the
Mathemagician did the trick how you kept
the lady in half you'll describe and
he'll say well you know he used 15
strokes in 20 seconds to cut the lady
into pieces that's what a mathematician
does he cannot tell you how the magician
did the trick that's what we want to
know that's where all the questions come
in the qualitative or you know the
explanatory part of the presentation we
want to know how the magician did the
trick that's what a mathematician is not
qualified or skilled to do he's an
autistic individual that's why he's not
only he only does equations and he's you
know is that doing X's and Y's that's
what he does all day and when you say
well you know how did the magician do
the trick you say oh I don't know nobody
can understand you know the how mother
nature does her tricks all we do is
describe it that's not science anybody
can describe its explaining that's where
you have to burn some gray neurons okay
okay so that's what thoughts says about
time what does he say about well yeah
about gravities as it's a force if you
don't believe me grab us a break again
he gets he loves the brick he says hold
it over your big toe not too high I
don't want you to injure yourself and
release it after you're done yelling in
pain tummy it is not a force well no the
point here is the point here is what do
you mean by force and again and the
point is that if you look at all his
answers these all come from core if you
look at Cora anything answered by Victor
Toth you will not see a single not one
definition of energy of mass of force he
has no idea what these words mean so he
tells you how to determine what a force
is let go of brick over your foot and
you'll know what a force is but he
hasn't told us what he means by the word
force and if you push him he'll say well
force is equal to to mass times
acceleration what the hell does that
mean what do you mean by force in
physics is very simple forces push or
pull there's only two forces in the
universe that you can imagine only for
two forms of contact but the
mathematicians have been invented four
of them they say there there's four
forces in the universe I don't know if
they're talking about horses maybe
they're talking about the four horses of
the apocalypsis maybe that's what
they're referring to I don't know maybe
they confuse the word force with a word
horse there's only two forces in the
universe there's only two forms of
contact we can imagine and that's push
and pull you either pull on the donkey
or you push them away that's it and if
anyone can imagine anything different
than that I want them to you know to
justify that and so you know in the
world of quantum they have the gluon
which and
graviton they're both forces of push of
pool I'm sorry they both pull glue on
poles quartz together grab batons
supposedly pull everything together you
know even distant stars and whatever and
there's two forms of push one is the
electromagnetic force which comes out of
the atom pushes outwards the photon and
there's the weak force also you know it
just pushes decaying matter out of the
atom so it's again there in to push and
pull
there's nothing how's that imagine a
mathematician can even imagine what is
this I mean there's only two forces push
and pull that's why I need for him to
define what he means by force otherwise
we have no idea what he's talking about
when he says oh it's equal to force a
force is equal to mass times
acceleration okay so what are we talking
about pusher cool what is force equals
times
massive is the thing coming towards me
or going away from me and is there a
third or fourth force that you can
imagine with force equals mass times
acceleration and again that's where he's
gonna bomb out he's not gonna be able to
do it mathematically or physically there
is absolutely no way okay what's another
thing that path does and again he
represents the mathematical
establishment he says that a particle is
any ball just use his own words
okay let's clarify something elementary
particles are not miniature cannon balls
that have a definite size okay
elementary particles are unit
excitations of quantum fields you got it
down pat yeah you got it right so we
have excitations of quantum fields
that's what a particle is so a particle
is not a bowling ball it's not even a
bead like the electron bead no
a particle is an excitation vibration or
whatever of a quantum field and then
obviously you got to go to the word
field you say okay what do you mean by
the word field I mean I thought a
particle was the corpuscle but now
you're saying it's a field what is a
field
well a field is just a value at each
point in space around a particle so so
let's get it right you know what is a
particle particle is a field and what is
the field the particle is a field is a
bunch of values around the particle so
we're back to the particle we've got the
circular definition until you know toth
can define what a field is and define it
as a physical object because obviously
if a field is a concept he can't say he
moved it he can't say that he kicked it
that it jumped that it moved around he
can't say any of that it's a concept and
so he says the particle moved but then
he said well a part of goes really a
field then he's got a contradiction and
we got to point that out to him stop him
right there he can't continue with his
presentation he can't continue with his
dissertation he's already being
irrational he's saying a particle is a
field in a field is a concept and a
concept cannot move he's already
violated one of the criteria for
rationality and he can object to the
criteria but then he's got to justify
why he objects to it and what he's going
to replace it with so we're back to you
know what isn't rational
and these people are irrational we
should not say well it's difficult it's
counterintuitive it's know we should say
it's irrational you're an irrational
individual because this is what you're
proposing this what you believe in and
we attack the theory but the
implications are very Adha minim very
direct to the person who is presenting
them right we stop them right there okay
and is there anything else yeah we have
another
last one here and that's that you know
these particles are point particles
they're not even particles and I'll
again I'll just use this word there is
no theoretical limit to this in
principle you can always increase the
interaction energy and confine the
elementary particle even more than
before no it doesn't make any difference
whether or not the particle is massive
so he doesn't care whether a particle
has again rest mass right but then he
says if a particle turns out to be
compound particle after all you know
like quarks they make up the proton and
the neutron those are composite you know
those are compound particles in other
words a proton is not an individual
particle neither is the atom which means
indivisible right so neither the atom
nor the proton or the neutron are
indivisible they are divisible
what are they divisible into they're
divisible into quarks now the question
is is the court divisible okay so people
ask these questions and this is where he
comes in then a sufficiently high
energies we might find that it's not
behaving like a point particle but just
like the proton reveals its substructure
or it is also possible that our
underlying theory quantum field theory
fails at a very high energies and very
high energies and whatever theory
replaces it will no longer predict
point-like behavior at very high
energies in other words he says we're
still investigating we're investigating
whether a quarte can be separated with
whether a quark can be broken up into
pieces and find out what it is made of
but to the extent that we currently know
currently no right that is to say
considering the theoretical predictions
of the standard model of particle
physics and the experimental results
from particle accelerators quarks are
indeed point light with no observable
spatial extent and no substructure what
is he saying he's saying that look as of
today
a quark is an elementary particle it's
an indivisible particle but give us more
funds give us more money
we'll build bigger and more powerful
accelerators we'll smash the quarks with
the high energies that we need to smash
quarks and we will tell you if it breaks
up into more particles and we'll call
that Johnny Peter and Tony so we'll have
more particles that comprise a quark
then you have to give us more money to
find out what Tony's made out of yeah
and and so it's an ever never-ending
quest to find out what particles are
made out of right now as of today the
quark is an indivisible point-like
particle but tomorrow we don't know so
today we call it an elementary particle
what does elementary or fundamental
particle mean mean it means that we have
we don't have enough money to break it
into pieces to find out what it's made
out of that's what it means
in other words quantum is is a religion
in the sense that it never never reaches
an end because from a conceptual point
of view there has to be a finite
particle a particle that makes up
everything but that's not what these
people are telling you they're saying
look it's elementary as of today
tomorrow we don't know so give us more
funds and we'll continue researching and
we'll tell you tomorrow not today okay
with that we adjourn and we'll see you
on Sunday the same time same station
remember there's a conference 10th of
November
Buenos Aires Argentina and for those who
signed up well we'll see you then
okay see you that buyback